‏j
[Silence]
الحذ بالله من الشيطان ال
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته السلام ورحمه الله
وبركاته الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله اشهد ان
محمد رسول
الله حي على الصلاه
حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح حي على
الفلاح الله اكبر الله
اكبر لا اله الا الا
الله سيدنا
[Silence]
محمد ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات
اعمالنا من يهده الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل
فلا هادي
له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك
له وان محمدا عبده
ورسوله صلى الله عليه وعلى اله وصحبه وسلم
تسليما كثيرا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم
مسلمون يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي
خلقكم من نفس واحده وخلق منها زوجها وبث
منهما رجالا كثيرا
ونساء واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به
والارحام ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا
قولا
سديدا يصلح لكم اعمالكم ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا
عظيما اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب
الله وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
وشر الامور
محدثاتها وكل محدثه بدعه وكل بدعه ضلاله
وكل ضلاله في
النار الله سبحانه
وتعالى كيت
[Silence]
الذي خلق الموت والحياه
ليبلوكم ايكم احسن
عملا الله
[Silence]
‏use
each
asked
one صلى الله عليه
وسلم
ترمي لا تزول قدما عبد يوم القيامه
حتى يسال عن عمره فيما افناه وعن علمه
فيما
فعل وعن ماله من اين اكتسبه وفيما انفقه
وعن جسمه فيما
ابلاه not
[Silence]
‏life
الله not
محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
حديث
ملم المؤمن
القوي خير واحب الى الله من المؤمن
الضعيف في كل
شيء وفي كل خير
احرس على ما
ينفعك واستعن
بالله استعن
بالله ولا
تعجز وان اصابك شيء فلا
تقف ولا تقل لو اني فعلت كذا او لو اني
فعلت كذا
وكذا ولكن قل
قدر الله وما شاء
فعل فان لو تفتح عمل
الشيطان الله
[Silence]
‏do
me
something do e
[Silence]
‏a ign
محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
[Silence]
حديث
الله اياك نعبد واياك
[Silence]
الله
حديث to us
up do not say if
only would
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
الله ح
‏pleasure and of
parad الله سبحانه
وتالى
from
life toing us to life from our
death to wake us up from
heedless and gu us to him سبحانه
وتعالى اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله لي
ولكم فاستغفروه انه هو الغفور الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على اشرف
الانبياء
والمرسلين سيدنا محمد عليه وعلى اصحابه
افضل الصلاه واتم التسليم
[Silence]
الله
ان سوره
المؤمنون هو الله سبحانه وتعالى والذين هم
عن اللغو
معرضون
الله محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
حثم محد صلى الله عليه
وسلم كان يؤ بالله واليوم الاخر فليقل
خيرا او
ليمت الله
حث in courts would
disappear many family ises would be
solved at much division between people
would be
solved the t
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم رب كلمه تهوي بك
سبعين
خريفه
every every word
‏we pay real att
to for life
every محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه
[Silence]
وتعالى سحان
الله don't
for media
وال do and everything you is going to
report
it
and behind the
screens
and a l of people unfor
muslims say things and they don't think
about them just because screens
‏face
are we here should hold
ourselves
we all
that weible
[Silence]
‏theal
mediating about
anything
the some people anything small
[Silence]
‏eit
har
are in a
‏they areed by angs and be of the recs
we
are on the day of
jud so whoever keeps focus on the after
life
say
silent this is a from
الله
asbes in
والذين لا يشهدون الزور واذا مروا باللغو
مروا
كراما
us وك الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏mind
make
make for
not the of
j
for cover our
mistakes our
wores and ff our
need for
[Silence]
الله may الله
all and make among those
اعلموا ان الله سبحانه وتعالى امركم بامر
فبدا به بنفسه فقال جل من
قائل ان الله
وملائكته يصلون على النبي يا ايها الذين
امنوا صلوا عليه وسلموا
تسليما اللهم صلي وسلم على عبدك ورسولك
محمد وارضى اللهم عن الاربعه الخلفاء
الراشدين
المهديين وعن بقيه الصحابه وعن التابعين
ومن تبعهم باحسان الى يوم الدين وعنا معهم
بعفوك وكرمك واحسانك يا ارحم
الراحمين اللهم اعز الاسلام والمسلمين
واذل الشرك والمشركين ودمر اعداءك اعداء
الدين اللهم ادفع عنا الغلاء والبراء
اللهم ادفع عنا الغلاء
والرياء اللهم ادفع عنا الغلاء والرياء
والربا والزنا والزلازل والمحن وسوء الفتن
ما ظهر منها وما بطن وعن سائر بلاد
المسلمين عامه يا رب
العالمين اللهم ثبتنا على قولك الثابت في
الحياه الدنيا وفي الاخره ربنا لا تزغ
قلوبنا بعد اذ هديتنا وهب لنا من لدنك
رحمه انك انت الوهاب واصلح اللهم واصلح
اللهم احوالنا في الامور كلها واختم اللهم
اللهم اختم واختم اللهم بالصالحات اعمالنا
وبسعاده
اجالنا وتوفنا يا ربي وانت راض عنا اللهم
اجعل جمعنا هذا جمعا مباركا مرحوما
وتفرقنا تفرقا معصوما ربنا لا تدع لنا
ذنبا الا غفرته ولا هما الا فرجته ولا
مريضا الا شفيته ولا ميتا الا رحمته
واجعلنا اللهم يا ربنا باسمك
متحابين وعلى نصره دينك
متعاونين اللهم اسبغ علينا نعمتك وعلى
جميع المسلمين واملا قلوبنا بالايمان
والقناعه والزم جوارحنا العباده والطاعه
واغفر اللهم لنا ولوالدينا ولاخواننا
ولجميع من سبقنا بالايمان واتنا من لدنك
رحمه وهيئ لنا من امرنا
رشدا اللهم اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار ان الله ان
الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذي
القربى وينهى عن الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي
يعظكم لعلكم تذكرون فاذكروا الله العظيم
الجليل يذكركم واشكروه على نعمه يزدكم
ولذكر الله اكبر والله يعلم ما
تصنعون
سبحان الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله
الا
الله اشهد ان محمد رسول
الله حي على الصلاه حي على الف فلاح قد
قامت الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله استووا استقيموا تراصوا يرحمكم
الله استووا تقاربوا
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الحمد الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليه
غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك
الاعلى الذي خلق
فسوى والذي قدر
فهدى
والذي اخرج
المرعى
فجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما شاء
الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما
يخفى
سنيس
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى
سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل
تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا
والاخره خير
وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله اكبر
[Silence]
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا
الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى
سيذكر من
يخشى
ويتجنبها الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا
والاخره
خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله اكبر
[Silence]
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
بس
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
‏first and for i personally
fores
ask
home hecl we
my as
was is also in ic as
الله الل افينا مضانر
الملمين
ition
something most of
you most you the name عائشه
نور
sister amer tur
ciot in west bank protest
so boys
boys i understand incident has happen
about a month and two months ag
[Silence]
الله الله
‏are ‏when they go for in the world and
continue doing the work you get the as
also starting we the security outside
has started ising little white papers
that says you are in violation if you
park in a wrong spot your license place
will be recorded by the security and if
you continue to keep doing what doing
outside in the parking then there will
be something
for al having said don on the way out
جزاك الله خيرا